growing up I really really didn't think
that I'd ever be able to kind of be all
of the things that I am and and also
still get to do all of this so this
award means so much to me thank you very
very much
Troye Sivan accepting the creative
conscience in film award at the Palm
Springs International Film Festival on
Friday I mean I'm so excited I feel like
throughout everything that I've done
I've always tried to kind of keep what I
stand for and what I believe in really
really close to my art and so um to be
you know like honored for both of those
things feels like a really really nice
just a nice acknowledgement I really
appreciate it so much
ET was with the boy race star before the
awards luncheon I'm not used to it
I'm really really enjoying it and having
a really good time also like every time
I I don't know I just I freak out every
time I come to it he also got over pal
ariana grande and his cameo in her thank
you next video I heard she's a lesbian
now in getting some chick called Aubrey
I mean when I first heard that song I
was like you don't understand this is
your biggest song like ever you you know
I I just remember being so so so happy
and and proud of her you know she is
she's just like the the strongest
cooler's person I know and so to be a
part of of that video which just kind of
felt like a celebration of resilience
her talent and you know it was such a
good time
I mean who wouldn't be obsessed of that
just like the best just the fattiest and
the coolest and most talented
[Music]